the best way to understand how bad the
conflict is in Sudan is perhaps to hear
directly from refugees
many people have lost their lives today
al-janaina has been transformed into
hell I want the United Nations to
intervene we don't live like people
we're not eating properly we don't have
health services we can't bear any more
of this
Mustafa a teacher says his country is no
longer a functioning State at the borata
displacement camp in Chad one after
another Refugee gives accounts of
running away from large groups of armed
men who roamed the countryside
terrorizing civilians most here are
women and children particularly
vulnerable to kidnapping and sexual
violence
the war is really bad a child silvering
breastfed can be killed alongside his
mother
his father can be killed there is
nothing good about war
witness to death they arrive traumatized
especially the youngest
we have to move them from the border
area to the safer place as well as we
have to move them where they can have
all the older assistance services such
as a school that a lot of parents
mentioned about that that they want to
send their children to schools as well
as health services that they can access
Aid groups say it's a Race Against Time
Reigns will come the camp will flood and
this remote area will become
inaccessible we were here just a few
days ago and there are already signs
that this Camp is getting bigger and
people are adapting to their
circumstances this is a makeshift Market
right in the middle of this dry riverbed
you can buy food shoes fruits
flashlights charge your cell phone you
can get soaps and biscuits really
anything people might immediately need
the other sign that this Camp is
changing that it's getting bigger is
that there are now makeshift tents on
both banks of the river
attempting to bring order to the chaos
the UN has started relocating people
at a camp in Gaga the newly arrived are
welcomed by Neighbors in a unique
position to empathize
Sudanese displaced from the same
Villages by the war in Darfur in 2003.
perhaps finding some Solace and seeing
life goes on living without fear of
attack is possible and children can go
back to school
something that will come as a comfort to
one teacher with a message to the
warring sides in Khartoum what you are
doing has killed thousands he says
silence the guns stop
the war
Eastern Chad
still ahead on out